Speaker 1: Let's go back to Discord and hear
from a few more people.
It's great to hear from people in the audience,
particularly on a day like today.
Let's go to Clark from Portland now.
Is that Portland, Maine, or Portland, Oregon,
my friend?
Speaker 3: That's Portland, Oregon.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I was I was actually just hopped on
the phone calls.
We didn't get a time to ask or think of a
question.
Oh, no.
So just send us someone else real quick.
Speaker 1: Oh, my gosh.
Well, can I ask you a question?
Absolutely.
Are you familiar with Hood River?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I love Hood River, actually.
Speaker 1: I'm potentially scheduled to go
to a wedding there next year.
Is this a place I would enjoy?
You think.
Speaker 3: It's beautiful?
I'll tell you what.
It's.
It's kind of right in between.
It's in the Cascade Gorge.
Okay.
So it's right in between the high desert and
kind of the coastal range.
And so it's a really nice mix of temperate
climate and a more arid climate.
Speaker 1: Yeah, gorgeous.
Sound pretty good.
I would.
I'm looking forward to that then.
All right.
Well, good luck, Clark.
Do you think of a question?
Okay.
Speaker 3: All right.
Have a good day.
Speaker 1: All right.
Very good.
There's Clark from Portland, who did not have
a question, but at least was able to answer
a little something for me.
Let's go next to Mark from Stockholm.
Mark, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hey.
Am I. Am I good?
Speaker 1: You are.
Are are you Swedish or are you an American
in Sweden?
Speaker 3: I am Swedish, actually.
Speaker 1: Beautiful.
I'm not shocked to hear your perfect English.
Speaker 3: Thank you.
Yes, France get older.
Anyway, so despite my.
Speaker 1: Okay, I hope that wasn't some horribly
racist statement.
No, no, no.
Speaker 3: I just said no, no.
I just said like I'm Swedish.
I promise.
Speaker 1: Okay, very.
Speaker 3: Good.
Very good.
I wouldn't do that.
But so, like, despite, you know, my tone of
voice, I actually do have like a really serious
question that I don't know if you feel equipped
to answer this, but I'm just going to take
a shot in the dark now.
Okay.
So recently, like, you know, myself, I'm like
a libertarian socialist.
My mom is like leaning heavily towards, like
the Christian white nationalist.
Far right.
Really?
Yeah.
And I have, like, no idea how to tackle this.
I don't know if I should be, you know, if
I should stand up for myself.
Because the thing is to like, I came out as
pansexual to her and she's totally just like
dismissive and rude about it, despite the
fact that prior to this, prior to recently,
she actually was so pretty like a liberal
leaning person.
Speaker 1: So if I understand correctly, your
mom is a Swedish white nationalist and you.
Speaker 3: I'm not going to.
Speaker 1: Hold on.
And then then you can correct it.
And you are a Swedish libertarian, socialist,
pansexual.
And there's conquest.
Speaker 3: Now.
Yes.
Wow.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
That's a big matzo ball hanging out there.
Speaker 3: I just want to I'd like to make
it clear, like, you know, I'm not going to
label her or anything.
I'm just saying that, like, she's leaning
heavily towards that.
I don't know definitively what she would identify
as.
Speaker 1: Is that a big is that a common
movement in Sweden?
Because Sweden is has the stereotype of being
so social democracy, left wing, you know.
Speaker 3: Yeah, well, I'll put it this way.
It's like the stereotype.
It actually adds fuel to the fire for a lot
of like far right movements in Sweden.
There actually is like a major like pretty
like far right party in government right now.
The Sweden Democrats, you know, like they've
definitely kind of like surfed the wave, if
you like.
You know, they basically basically like benefited
greatly from this huge influx of people, you
know, looking at immigration and saying, like,
hey, you know, we're taking in too many people.
You know, they look around at like, you know,
people have even like posted pictures on,
like, Swedish subreddits and like, you know,
it's like, okay.
Speaker 1: Now let's watch the language because
then we're going to have to bleep it.
Pat, please make it.
We need a.
Speaker 3: Group that can say anything.
Speaker 1: Oh, I thought you just dropped
the nest bomb.
Did you not just drop in Aspen?
Speaker 3: Oh.
Speaker 1: No, no, no.
Now you dropped another one.
Okay.
All right, everybody, let's let's let's let's
see if we can get away from this.
I have no advice about the mom thing.
Question Remind me what pansexual is.
Speaker 3: So pansexual is essentially this
idea that I'm not limited to gender when it
comes to attraction.
So like I've found men, women non-binary,
people attractive.
That's basically the gist of it.
And by the way, sorry for like cursing.
It's a force of habit I'll try not to do.
Speaker 1: No, that's okay.
So basically pansexual, it's sort of like
whatever sexual any adult.
Speaker 3: Exactly.
Got it.
It got it's like if I find somebody attractive,
they're attractive no matter what.
Their gender identity is beautiful.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, I appreciate the call and the insight.
And by the way, do you speak English with
some of your Swedish friends?
Like how do you speak English so.
Well, it's so common in Sweden.
Speaker 3: I make YouTube videos and I listen
to a lot of comedians from the US.
So that's about.
Speaker 1: It.
Got it.
Hey, and by the way, this and we're now getting
off topic.
It is interesting that in Sweden everybody
speaks American English like you would think
being so close to the UK you might everybody
there might learn British English.
But it's not the case.
Speaker 3: You would, you would think and
also I was taught like the UK version of the
English and so all but I never jived with
it.
So I just kind of like went along with like
standard like Northern American English.
Speaker 1: Got it, got it.
All right, very good.
Well, I really appreciate the call and your
insights.
Speaker 3: Yeah, no problem.
Thanks for having me.
Here we go.
Out.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Mark from Stockholm.
Really?
I mean, saying it all, saying it all and only
two bleeps necessary.